with martial arts brawler sifu developer
sloclap is hoping to capture the meaning
of kung fu creating an experience of
learning and mastery through practice
according to slo-clap ceo and co-founder
pierre tarno that means you should
expect to die a lot as you brawl your
way through the game but as you do
you'll become older wiser and stronger
both as a player and as a character slow
clap recently gave gamespot a hands-off
look at three of sifu's five different
levels providing us with a more complete
look at what your quest for revenge will
actually play like if you enjoy this
video and you want to see more coverage
of sifu in the future make sure to hit
the like and subscribe buttons below
if you played absolver slo-clap's last
martial arts game you'll have an idea of
what sifu is like you play a kung fu
student whose family is murdered and you
set out on a one-day quest for revenge
against the five kung fu fighters
responsible to get to them you have to
battle your way through five different
levels filled with each of the boss's
fighters and each level is themed on a
different element in chinese philosophy
wood fire water earth and metal those
levels are each set in a different
location in a fictional chinese city but
tarnow told us that as you venture
deeper into each one they'll become less
and less realistic and more and more
fantastical as the theme of their
elements builds in combat sifu will
probably be pretty familiar to fans of
games with similar martial arts combat
like absolver you execute combos through
different combinations of light and
heavy attacks while also dodging
blocking and parrying your enemies moves
tarno said players should expect the
game to be pretty challenging and we got
that impression from the hands-off
presentation enemies come at you fast
and often in big groups requiring you to
learn how to deal with their moves
isolate fighters and control the crowd
you can't just block your way to victory
you have a gauge that measures your
guard strength and as you take hits or
block blows it fills up indicating when
your guard will be broken and leaving
you stunned enemies also have a similar
gauge indicating when you can bust
through their guard leaving them open
for a quick takedown that knocks them
out of the fight with a cinematic
flourish while also replenishing some of
your health
[Music]
so there's an incentive to play
aggressively especially because you can
take a beating and lose your health
pretty quickly thanks to a special
amulet that you wear being defeated
doesn't mean you die you just pop right
back up and go on brawling however your
age progresses significantly every time
you die and if you age too much on a run
it's game over we didn't see too much of
the aging mechanic in action but tarnow
told us a bit about how it works he said
the fantasy at play is the idea of
becoming a wise master becoming more
powerful and knowledgeable the older you
get but of course getting old has its
drawbacks the system is still being
solidified but the general idea is that
the older you get the better a kung fu
fighter you become so your hits will be
more powerful and land with more
precision the drawback is that getting
older takes a toll on your body slow
clap doesn't want you to become weaker
as you age because it doesn't want to
lock you into a loop where the more you
die the more likely you are to die again
until it's game over but your character
will have less health as they age so
you'll have to be more and more
aggressive as you get older taking down
enemies more quickly to keep them from
taking you down we saw three different
locations from the game an apartment
building a nightclub that houses a
secret fight club and a museum each one
presents different environments to fight
through and it's essential that you pay
attention to your surroundings because
taking advantage of the space around you
is key to staying alive you can
consistently use your environment in
combat and really it's essential in the
apartment building you fight your way up
a big central staircase which means you
can throw enemies over the railing into
space if you're close to a wall you can
bounce an enemy's head off it or throw
them into it pushing someone down a
flight of stairs or out a window helps
you to eliminate enemies quickly and
anything from empty glass bottles to
pieces of furniture can potentially be a
weapon to give you the upper hand from
the looks of things sifu's combat is all
about keeping control of the situation
or getting out of harm's way quickly at
one point in the nightclub the player
was backed into a corner and so quickly
scrambled up some decorative lattice to
a higher floor later in the nightclub
the player quickly rolled over a couch
to get some distance on some enemies who
were closing in you could also unlock
different moves that let you throw
enemies into one another swap places
with them or knock them down unlocking
these moves and working them into your
combos allows you to constantly be
thinking about how to control the fight
even when facing overwhelming odds the
same goes for when you're fighting
enemies with weapons knock an enemy down
and you disarm them so you want to be
thinking about how to get enemies off
their feet and out of the fight before
they slash you with a machete or nail
you with a baseball bat finally fighting
well builds up a gauge for your
character called focus when you've got
enough focus you can briefly slow down
time allowing you to pick from a group
of powerful moves that have special
effects one focus move might leave an
enemy stunned while another might knock
them down or do extra damage you can
also unlock moves specific to the
weapons you can find and use like blades
to deal massive damage under the right
circumstances it seems like sifu will
have a whole lot of options for fighting
and it might be a lot to keep track of
tarnow said the player character has
around 150 different moves all created
with the help of a real-life pakmy kung
fu master and that doesn't count the
many takedown moves but you won't have
access to every move every time you play
the game instead it'll take you time to
unlock various different abilities and
for a while you'll only have those
abilities for the specific run you're
actually playing at that time as you
rack up combos and beat enemies you'll
earn experience points you can then
spend at certain places to unlock new
moves either shrines you find in levels
which convey something like perks that
only last through a given run of the
game or at your wu
the dojo you return to between levels
but while you can unlock a move during a
run you'll lose it if you age out and
die until you've spent enough points to
unlock it permanently that'll give you
time to figure out which abilities you
like and want to use in your kung fu and
which you don't that gave sifu a bit of
a roguelike flare although tarnow
clarified that each level and each
encounter is handcrafted they're not
random what's different each time is the
set of perks and moves you might have
unlocked especially as you fight and age
there are also elements of randomness as
you play through a given level if you
efficiently wail on a group of enemies
one might surrender allowing you to
avoid fighting them or even question
them for information another enemy in
the same situation might become the last
man standing gaining a health boost and
unlocking additional combos to become
something like a mini boss all the
enemies have access to the same moves
you do so fighting these new characters
will be a test of your knowledge and
experience and they can pop up
semi-randomly so there are rogue-like
elements at play in sifu mixing up the
play of a straightforward action game
but you'll also be unlocking things that
will persist between runs through the
game tarno described another element a
menu called the detective board where
you'll gather information about each of
the bosses and the levels as you play
through them the more info you have the
more paths you might unlock in a level
allowing you to access shortcuts or
avoid fights again the theme is mastery
through practice so you'll replay levels
over and over learning their ins and
outs and gathering info on your
detective board while also becoming a
better fighter and unlocking more and
more moves though we only saw three
brief sections of the game it seems like
all these systems will work together to
make sifu a pretty deep action
experience but one that's excitingly
cinematic the focus on paying attention
to and using the environment makes for
some great moments like one in which the
player battles a gang of enemies in a
museum exhibit with a giant kunai shaped
pendulum there are also moments where
the camera will shift perspective like a
hallway full of enemies that suddenly
adopts a side-scrolling perspective
which tarnow said was an homage to the
movie old boy and to classic 2d brawlers
expect the game to run at 60fps on both
playstation 4 and playstation 5 tarno
said and in 4k on ps5 it all makes sifu
look like an impressive if tough and
demanding action game one in which
you'll want to keep practicing to become
a kung fu master sifu is set to release
on ps4 ps5 and pc on february 22nd
[Music]
you